[Musique]
aie aie
et
oh
oui bon
[Musique]
pas
oh oui
ouah
et
bienvenue en thalasso dont l'une est
excellent avec georges
d'abord il met les dix cafés photos
interviews easy le boy ici des world
pour sa super cover de google goog et
[Musique]
florent pagny interview j'aime j'aime
pas joli à ford avec lui et leurs
acteurs de la part de thierry pour son
papa interview zouk olympe et couturiers
réflexion sur la question deuil
brabbi au numéro 2020
nathalie cardone la révélation de grudd
endroit pour une rencontre là cette opé
village avec free lunettes et cetera
inaugure sa séquence s'enfonçant
pur-sang cariou interview signalement de
la star humaine l'ours en peluche lionel
jean jacques le plus grand bonheur des
bassistes plus bastista dit ranger
vas-y le club pour l'amérique contre
roger rabbit au quartier là car bien sûr
valérie bichette la caprice quatre noms
question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sais pourquoi j'ai une petite idée
oui pourquoi la connerie parce que c'est
un film à je manie de très bien je me
suis alors imagine sais pas je me rends
compte dans une boîte de nuit un soir de
mai supérieur comment tu me le racontait
et moi je te dis écoute les bornes
d'échappée la bomba latina dépasse km
avec le président hu est
et puis y attirer très bon nombre de
principes alors que des biens sociaux
autrement pas mal du tout je mets fin à
ma vie et c'est une histoire qu'on n'a
jamais traité cinéma actuel 16 passes en
1944 dans les créations dont elle a eu
des films sont ailleurs oui mais pas des
opérations les créations des collabos
c'est l'époque on trouvait les flammes
étaient faux ouais c'était pas très
détendu en film non parce que j'ai pas
trahi mais j'ai quelqu'un qui a
travaillé à s'en sortir quelqu'un qui
veut se racheter de se racheter des
papiers d'identité une bonne conscience
un futur donc je suis une femme
amoureuse s'est sacrifié hier est en
fait bon c'est pour ça que je les fais
tu es poussé par un premier gros c'est
un rôle si tu veux un second rôle très
intéressant parce que ça me permettait
de montrer mon côté tendre général
je connais très bien mais le grand
public ne connaît pas obligatoire
d'enquêté qui se sacrifie pour lan
quesnel
donc voilà ce que j'en dirai plus
dramatique oif et de recherche
je vais voir très bien sa fine équipe
comptant réalisateur josé giovanni
y'a pas du solide en chine oui a dit
sony s'est passé
vingt cinq semaines de cette troisième
petit traître à me proposer ses services
nous dans la balance il faut tout mettre
vous a aidé ces buttes loupé croire son
achat
la france et maisons de correction at au
judo rien tu connais la question qu'ont
les questions encore
ouais comment vous avez commencé ouais
bon ça c est très content moi ça juste
un peu moins
mais
[Musique]
par exemple si tu conduis est ce que tu
préfères passé une nuit avec un mec que
tu aime à la folie et
ou une semaine avec un mec que tu aimes
moyennement c'est vraiment une question
super coureur passé même une demie nuit
avec l'homme que j'aime évidemment alors
et si tu étais obligé pas un jour que
j'ai faite prisonnière
on te dit ouais c'est une idée comme ça
tout c'est un jeu c'est ça la vraie
c'est la question qu'ont alors j'ai
faite prisonnière et puis on te dit
voilà qui est obligé de faire l'amour
avec la personne avec qui on va t'en
fermés dans cette cellule tu vois la
situation est ce que tu préfères faire
l'amour avec une fille ou avec les
raisons qui l'ont poussé à
l'homosexualité alors je sais pas moi il
ya des gens qu'elle a l'air à huawei
non c'est pas trop demander en france tu
préfères la fille jamais essayé les
films et je crois que si j'étais obligé
je préfère encore essayé définitif à
définitif aux gens recevoir des lettres
ce gars fin j'ai pas encore sécurisée
alors maintenant question impossible à
mon sens mais certaines personnes
peuvent y répondre
est ce que tu préfères renault gugelmann
2 3
je sais pas s'il ya un long silence
n'arrive pas je n'arrive pas mais j'en
étais sûr à mon avis c'est une question
à laquelle peu de chanteurs réponse n'a
pas honoré goldman à dire comment je
cale pour qui tu as le plus de
circonstances atténuantes un à qui tu
trouve le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux mecs qui se tape des petites
filles ça pour l'argent ou alors un
jeune mec qui toujours pour l'argent
tapent sur des vieilles vraiment paniqué
ce type auront alors tu as bien compris
la question oui oui maintenant j'essaie
d'imaginer le tableau est bien calme le
plus noir je te demande pas de m oui je
pardonne aux jeunes
tu pardonnes jeunes qui tapent sur des
vieilles weppes et sauf et c'est ce
qu'il est obligé de s'en sortir à bon il
est pas bon d'accord alors que l'autre
il est pas obligé de payer des petites
filles non à l'autre c'est un pervers
si tu rentres chez toi soir avec un
garçon de six mois prévu qu rentrer avec
lui un c'est pas ton fiancé habituel etc
c'est un garçon tu as rencontré genre la
première question coup de foudre
et puis tu as oublié quelque chose sur
la table de nuit
un objet assez compromettants sur ma
table de nuit
oui avant je suis immense chez moi oui
tu le ramène chez toi femme vient chez
toi janvier quoi été oublié qu'est ce
qui te gêne le plus d'avoir oublié mein
kampf ou un godemichet
ah c'est terrible y a rien sur ma table
de nuit
mais tu peux pas répondre la pièce qu'il
devienne le plus vis-à-vis du avec ce
mec a envie de le montrer
vis-à-vis de lui si tu veux tu veux
montrer que tu es une fille bien et tout
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il devienne le
plus de vignes moi je crois que c'est
mind comme il m'a quand même fait mais
bon deuxièmement site était amputé d'un
membre sur ces tragiques
on va être obligé de vous amputé d'un
membre et on est obligé toi c'est un jeu
alors lequel un bras ou une jambe un
bras
d'abord lequel le bras droit ou le bras
gauche de gauche évidemment je droitière
et site était maître du monde
tu ferais quoi demain matin entre
éveillant puis devient maître du monde
sa maîtresse du monde cette instabilité
énorme diamètre du monde et la première
chose que tu fais
ce serait aidé les gens je sais pas
comment site maîtres du monde peut faire
plein de rythme et est requis en
première
j'ai dû tout l'argent que les
prisonniers politiques déjà dans tous
les pays
ouais mais dans tous les pays déjà il ya
du boulot est-ce beaucoup de boulot et
puis ensuite je taxe je m'appelle je
texte toutes les denrées alimentaires
stockées en surgelé web monde entier les
gens voient dans les pays sous alimentés
parce qu'il ya des aliments stockées en
surgelé qu'on sort pas tout simplement
parce que votre pas que les prix
baissent pas d'alimentation est ce ça me
met hors de moi alors qu'on envoie des
cartons de protéines
c'est tout d'abord ses jumelles alors
donc les maîtres du monde peut tout
changer
ou est-ce que tu mettrais la france sur
la carte du monde tu pouvais choisir
tout d'assurer la je vais amel actifs
je suis la maîtresse à se réunissent
dans l'océan monsieur sympathique parce
qu'une grande polynésie quoi rencontrer
les palm oil et paris tu le mets très
haut par rapport à ça
la pari bien situé sauf va oui je
mettrai pas à cannes par hasard
ben non non non je te parlais d'un titre
dernière question kong je te dis la
bombe arrive dans cinq minutes
la bombe atomique ouais elle va tomber
sur paris pile sur la concorde
qu'est ce que tu fais dans les cinq
dernières minutes
je vais t'aider je sais pas écouté mon
fiancé la proximité je me jette dans ses
bras toute sa vie c'est là nous on a dû
polémique quand même mais je crois qu'un
mac y réagiraient production mais je
crois que c'est dans un moment par
ailleurs on a besoin surtout de se
sentir va se sentir seule fois collé
contre lui tu attends de satan point je
fais pas une prière par hasard donc pour
l'au delà
ouais c'est pas mon genre tu es sur
l'année au ciel or je sais pas du tout
si les goudes la grande copine de ronny
bkx le cerveau du train postal réfugié
au brésil
pas étonnant qu'elle ait toujours pire à
que les idées des autres et que son
premier pub soit une pomme
boogie woogie en 78 était belle
stéphanie
[Musique]
bush
monsieur
[Musique]
mais
m
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
oui
du coup
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
et
je
[Musique]
en cure
[Rires]
[Musique]
comment
ouais
oui
[Musique]
bon
mettez vos lunettes noires pour la nuit
blanche fiche old boy george pour le
palace le vent joue les dj le disque on
a choisi nous c'est don't cry son
nouveau 45 tours image si la meilleure
je suis
tu veux
c
non
m
les fruits
on
[Musique]
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
ma sexualité
ap
ça soupire un jour ils ont quitté
philadelphie pour la californie avec une
subaru et 300 dollars aujourd'hui il
enregistre chez brink's à minneapolis
preston c'est normal que nous l'avons
chebec dépendent
[Musique]
fille
e
oui
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
de quoi
il peut
[Musique]
oh
mais
[Applaudissements]
abel
[Musique]
le caennais
[Rires]
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
là
m
[Musique]
aucune
et
florent pagny en de koné pour n'importe
quoi et quand on dit que tu es le
nouveau sardou ça t'emmerde
ça fait presque quand j'enregistre à
n'importe quand je suis aux fins
camériste à mélanger l'eau avec qui j'ai
faibli ce qu'il était toujours là pour
lui ces lycées redouble et en plus rock
on va faire comme chez drucker c'est
quoi tes projets un étranger un prochain
le 10 mai qui soit je vois une équipe et
je fasse appel laissez nous respirer un
45 tours ont besoin de chansons j'ai
besoin de savoir un peu
c'était l'effet du hasard ou une chance
si ça venait vraiment de ce que je sais
la mélodie est aussi bien les paroles de
ses biens
merci
généralement il
question on ne sait pas si le film le
plus génial de noël c'est pas dans
les grands films
elle est un été 42 s'il n'est plus
contagieux ces derniers temps
le film le plus con que j'ai vu ces
derniers temps je vais aux etats unis
c'est un truc vicitmes sur gt une
lamborghini que leur principal du début
jusqu'à la fin
le pays qui prévoit lever que je préfère
je crois que c'est le mien en quoi le
pays qui déteste le plus je crois que
vous poussez vous en aux pauvres et je
crois que c'est les états unis avant
pourquoi pas ce que
il n'y a pas d'âme quoi ça m'a fait bien
passé je viens de passer un mois et
avant que j'y retourne il va passer
beaucoup
ouais je trouve que
il ya peut-être votre linge ou 20 ans ça
doit être génial à voir pour nous
maintenant on a tous vu à la télé en
photo aux informations sans les serrer
dans les séries alors les grandes
voitures les grands immeubles et puis
vont les
jour alors que jamais vus adopté
recommencé à parler il employait la vie
avant souvent la même chose israël chose
c'est vrai que c'est très superficielle
je crois que c'était un peu les gens
vers le côté superficiel et j'y suis
allé dans cette prison mais on sait bien
là des hommes politiques alors
maintenant c'est une drôle de challenge
mais j'aime bien me dérange pas très
branché politique et j'ai pas de temps
dans ces pages et pas par 6 mai
le personnel je crois que ce mec me
fascine beaucoup je le trouve très malin
sauf que c'est un mec franchement très
malin et ça oui j'aimerais vraiment
rencontré jeudi c'est un mec qui sait où
c'est possible on l'a réglé mes
salutations d'un plaisir mais c'est vrai
que c'est un mec que je crois voyant et
le mec le plus ringard en politique
vraiment là je sais pas s'il est
franchement ringarde mais qui me fait
rire c'est croisic et ouais j'ai fait
j'ai déconné je regarde que le pmu
stirbois mais le pen j'ai même pas envie
je sais pas qui s'écrasé fils et
servi faits réels être franchement
ringarde son attitude et sa manière de
parler de faux chéri je trouve que c'est
que ces limites thermiques nature le
plus gros coup de fouet que t'es fait
c'est quoi c'est n'importe quoi à porter
et à plus gros serait plus grosses
pertes peu après le coup de se planter
comme lui planter c'est pour moi qui ai
vraiment tordu c'est un signe s'appelle
blessure que j'ai écrit ouais j'ai bien
fait jouer en hiver tu avais mon père ma
mère tous mes potes et puis on sait avec
l'arrivée au tél
ben moi je suis assez content d'avoir
vécu cette histoire et ça m'a appris
plein de choses mais c'est vrai qu'il
est resté qu'une semaine à la fois un
record la plus grande joie ta carrière
c'est ce qui est un peu ce qui s'est
passé quoi ouais en fait la plus grande
joie sélection
ça faisait dix ans que
que sans être obstiné parfois et
je me disais un jour il va se passer
quelque chose avec la chanson c'est
tellement bon élément que je vais je
fais du cinéma c'est formidable
j'apprends plein de choses et ça
peut-être m'ouvrir des portes après pour
justement la chanson mais mais d'arriver
à faire cette chanson de composer la
musique alors que jamais elle est
composée de faire de décrire les paroles
alors que même mes parents ils portent
et je leur ai clairement donc avant
d'aller je me dis
injection d'un test pour une réception
de ta carrière bon tu sais moi j'ai eu
plusieurs petites dépecé de déception
qui à la fin on finit par avec une honte
c'est que pendant huit ans de carrière
de cinéma je me suis toujours trouvé un
peuple et d'ailleurs je suis toujours
collés sur les gros coup des choses
importantes comme vivacom allons enfants
comme souvenirs souvenirs où j'arrivais
le deuxième mais franchement le deuxième
volet metteur en scène m'appelait en
disant écoute si on fait le film d'amos
avec toi compte me refaire d'autres
essais pour voir et après je me
reconnais toujours le dernier en fin de
compte c'était cette accumulation de cas
où je lisais quand même mon pote il ya
un moment il va falloir qu'il se passe
quelque chose là l'histoire d'amour la
plus belle histoire d'amour
j'en ai vécu des olives on a vécu
aujourd'hui soit la plus belle
elle a commencé quand j'avais 11 ans
heureusement j'ai rencontré
typhi kahn avait dit sûr
sur le mur d'un village où
où j'habitais
quand j'avais pas là donc et en savoie
haute savoie très bonne ville la petite
fille habitait réalisé dans ce coup j'ai
vu cette fille et jusqu'à 18 19 ans
cette fille là m'a pris la tête je n'ai
jamais je suis devenu le meilleur copain
de son frère abel et tout et c'est vrai
que c'est des gens
moore et tout ça je les aime et le site
je l'aimais comme un scoop mais c'est
comme ça puis un jour à 18 19 ans j'ai
dit beauchemin verra plus jamais revu
depuis mai mais c'est quelle est cette
jeune fille m'a pris tous mes rêves
quand même de 10 à 19 ans la plus ratée
du soir est la plus ratée d'histoire
c'était fini ce temps j'ai vécu il
tel qu'il ya quelques années en deux
j'ai traversé le monde pour rejoindre
une femme magnifique est assez
incroyable et je suis arrivé il ya là
des allocs
c'est pas mal c'est comique au bar avec
des épaves au co2 si la partie de toi tu
déteste le plus c'est thème le pull
c'est quoi ce que tu préfères en toi par
exemple c'est quoi ce que je préfère en
moins
je crois que c'est
c'est mon énergie gwagenn de l'énergie
ça veut dire l oise
la vitesse est ce que tu déteste le plus
intense
ce que je déteste en plus en moi des
fois c'est
c'est la connerie que chacun on peut
avoir un moment donné dans sa vie ou
même dans sa journée je crois qu'avant
franchement devenir qu'on est des fois
je vais arriver je me retourne et les
témoins d'autres kung fu de camélat
julien ford a eu marre de faire la
choriste et jingle de pub elle s'écrie
happy ever after
il
un mois
[Musique]
c'est
la bière
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
comme chez
qu'est-ce que
le
merci
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique]
ce domaine
elle
je ne
non
[Musique]
il
legault
oh
on
m
mais
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ans
et
[Applaudissements]
elana
[Musique]
basile de koch tuer le président de jal
on sait quoi jalons qui nous rassemble
c'est cette idée qui lie à un vide et
c'est sur cette idée de vie que nous
avons construite démarche est que nous
avons construit notre
philosophie en quelque sorte qu'est ce
que j'appellerais une théologie de
l'aberration
c'est à dire que nous voulons montrer le
réel dans sa vacuité alors dans un
univers où
la falsification ne vient la réalité est
ce que l'imaginaire n'est pas plus vrai
que le réel d'où l'idée de jalons qui
pastiche tout ce qui bouge dans la
dernière fois qu'on a entendu parler des
jalons très sérieusement s'il ya
quelques jours lors de la sortie du film
qui veut la peau de roger la peindre g
rabbit ou jalon a pris fermement
position contre la caricature de lapin
qu'on donne à travers roger rabbit
finalement c'est ça oui parce que ça a
été pour nous un insupportable et comme
le disait vraiment mon genou quand les
bornes sont franchies n'y a plus de
limites mais alors à quoi on a assisté
dans ce film à la présentation d'une
sorte de caricature de lapin grand test
avec des oreilles énorme un gros nez
rouge et des dents de lapin
alors déjà c'est insupportable mais en
plus au moment de l'ouverture de la
chasse
ça constitue une véritable provocation
pour nos frères rongeurs c'est ce que
nous nous sommes dits nous nous sommes
dit alors non seulement on les tue
physiquement mais ont réussi les blessé
moralement alors ça n'est pas
supportable et c'est pour ça que nous on
réagit et nous avons lancé un appel très
large sans distinction de l'opinion nous
avons
recruter des hommes politiques des
associations les hommes politiques ça
allait de jean-marie lapins angoras
ville de paris oui les associations ça
pouvait aller de l'union départementale
des lapins de garenne colombes
jusqu'à la ligue contre le racisme
garantie d'un pénis mme remplaçant par
les fours du nord et tous ensemble nous
sommes réunis pour protester contre ce
film scandaleux et donc le 12 octobre
nous étions tous unis dans la rue lapin
et non la fin fraternellement unis mains
dans la pâte pour lutter contre ce film
sera-t-il atteint en plein coeur de
saint germain des prés et nous avons je
ne me reconnais maintenant remporté un
succès puisque au bout d'une semaine de
projection ce film a fait dix fois
moindres entrées qu'aux états unis
c'est comparable après ce qui s'est
passé avec le film de scorsese ya eu des
écoutes et chers amis il faut pas tout
mélanger chacun porte sa croix celle de
lapin déjà séjourné est ce que le fait
par exemple qu'un film comme le grand
bleu les dauphins jean jacques annaud
l'ours roger rabbit et lapins est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une volonté comme ça
d'utiliser les animaux à des fins
commerciales finalement alors là dessus
j'ai envie de dire deux choses d'une
part on ne veux pas comparer l'ours de
jean jacques annaud
on filme scandaleux de spielberg parce
que dans le film de spielberg
comme je vous le disais on présente une
caricature de la faim dans laquelle je
ne me reconnaît nullement en revanche
jean jacques annaud a eu l'honnêteté de
faire appel à un véritable ouf oui ne
lui donnez la parole librement et à la
limite je dirais de se mettre dans sa
peau c'est très différent comme démarche
d'autre part et pour le reste pour la
question que vous posez en ce qui
concerne l'utilisation d'animaux dans
les films je ne suis pas du tout opposé
c'est positif alors l'association qui
regroupe cette lutte anti roger rabbit
s'appelle le clapier ça tiens pourquoi
adapter le clapier c'est le comité de
liaison des amis les animaux à poils et
à plumes pour l'intégration entre de
réciproque mais c'est un mouvement que
nous avons créé pour l'occasion en
regroupement comme jeu
des genres et de tous les univers du jeu
d'origine maori mais ça reste quand même
jalons qui est à l'initiative de ce
mouvement parce que jalon est toujours
le premier sur la brèche pour se battre
pour la défense tous les opprimés contre
les oppresseurs et éventuellement
linverse si c'est nécessaire mais
qu'elle est l'association derrière tout
ça je veux dire parce que jalons
interview à ja l'on sait qui présent sur
tous les fronts mais qui dirige tout ça
c'est une question difficile parce que
c'est en réalité jalons fait partie
d'une organisation secrète qui s'appelle
la main occulte qui tire les fils mais
je ne devrais peut-être pas le dire à la
télévision
et cette association alors on peut tout
dire choisir cette association a pour
but un moyen terme et faire de nous les
maîtres du monde avec un vrai c'est bien
parti ont duré quatre heures
il vous posons déjà dans les mois qui
viennent quelles sont les initiatives
que va prendre jalons pour continuer son
action à nous avons un certain nombre de
projets mais nous n'avons pas parlé de
nos activités nos parents de nos futurs
projets alors nos futurs projets il y en
a plusieurs
d'abord nous envisageons le 1er novembre
pour la fête de la toussaint
de faire une grande soirée à la mémoire
de nos disparus
on connaissait nos grands disparus félix
point marcel dassault et le werder et
georges pompidou et cette soirée donc
aura lieu le 1er novembre au studio un
champs elysées et elle aura lieu avec
deux groupes un groupe de rock
alternatif que j'aime beaucoup dans plus
que je n'ai jamais entendu encore
s'appelle karbala à 400 prêtres et puis
surtout pour la première fois en europe
et avant montboudif les dettes pont pie
xii
cette année vainement à oui c'est un
événement très parisien est ce que vous
allez faire des lettres confidentielles
utiliser le minitel les grands médias
parce que cette fusion déjà tout ça
parce que jalon est une organisation
multimédia et
nous avons une lettre confidentielle
dans laquelle on peut lire régulièrement
et avant les autres à condition d'être
abonné pour un prix modique
on peut lire tout ce qui aurait pu se
passer si c'était nous qui décidons nous
avons aussi un réseau militaire qui est
bourré de révélations
je qualifierais d'explosifs je peux vous
en citer par exemple dans le dernier
minitel que nous sortons nous expliquons
de quelle manière jean marie le pen ont
déclaré qu'il n'était pas antisémite a
provoqué une très grave crise au sein du
front national
à bischheim erding est dominik robichaud
avignon
après freddy ça fait du bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
tant pis
six mois
[Musique]
jane
ce biseau
[Musique]
et
à lyon
[Musique]
l'espagne
tél
[Musique]
/
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
je sais
bayonnais jeu
dallas
et
où
[Musique]
eh ben
je
m
[Musique]
élu
j'ai quitté
du jour
[Musique]
et
bon
en
[Musique]
m
si on aime
[Musique]
le guet
non ici
m
[Musique]
tchéky karyo bonsoir va commencer par
une petite interview signalement vous
aviez à 12 appareils
ça vient du fils d'un un turc devrait
aussi des gens qui venaient d'espagne
eux j'aurais aimé qu'elle est compliquée
tiens une grande turquie en grèce
ouais ouais je suis dans istanbul et
j'ai grandi en france et chez qui ça
surtout après l'an financer un prénom
ans après donc ouais on m'appelle comme
ça à istanbul en france rappelle jacques
hyest
et pourtant sûrement c'est quoi et pas
sur nous à bâtir leur nom dans
l'intimité belgique et 11 ans cheikh
aweys est bien la nationalité c'est quoi
espagnol français français pensent que
ça passe par conséquent pas ce qu'on
fera travailler à changer français comme
tout le monde et france est aussi
français que toi six ans et que soit sa
date de naissance 53 54 ans a finalement
appelé les chaînes particulier s'ils
pensent que je sais pas moi des
tatouages dément les grandes bottes et
si quelques cicatrices araujo j'ai
failli y en avoir une à cause du groupe
familial on y célébrait c'est à vous
qu'il appelle la boîte et que moi comme
hocine particulier tard il ya des
maladies chroniques vous allez acheter
ses parts une jour provient d'un mètre
80 c'est à savoir la presse combien je
pèse
je sais pas je me suis pas posée était
un bon temps je sais pas après c'était
dans ça va mais non
tes cheveux tu les perds pas un petit
peu ça se voit par entre le coeur et l
école ouais t'as fait quoi que j'ai fait
j'allais être expert comptable avant de
jouer la colonne tulle échappé bel air
est ce que tu as fait l'armée jadis fort
mais je racontais des histoires
j'ai raconté les historiques des défauts
je lui est étranger raconter n'importe
quoi il faut tu vas voir les films des
autres c'est quoi
je vais voir j'aime beaucoup wenders
merci
certains découvrir
un cinéaste que je trouve génial qui
s'appelle leur stand flyers qui avaient
fait clinique et danois j'avais fait les
matons prime
le dernier qu'il a fait qu'il va sortir
bientôt d'ailleurs s'appelle épidémique
que je trouve génial auxerre une femme
n'était que quand j'ai vu pour la
première fois face aux verts
c'est certain
racine et à ses moteurs en turquie a des
choses à raconter et j'ai envie de
travailler avec lui à la télé ou en tout
cas de quoi lasser
le ciné-club lunettes noires pour sa
session non bien sûr
e
je regrette beaucoup rapidement sous le
nom de code le premier j'imagine les
mots
par ailleurs pour musique tu écoutes
quoi j'adore le rythm and blues
là j'ai dans ma bagnole aretha franklin
une semaine
ce jour avec la journée des barrières il
entend depuis 12 ans maintenant ça se
passe bien et pas de problème donc ça se
passera bien et des enfants j'ai une
petite fille 10 à 12 ans non j'ai une
bombe était aux kings d'abord elle et
toi t'es sûr ouais elle aimerait c'est
branché sexe oui c'est pas que tu prêtes
à 27 c quoi je préfère un sexe
il
j'aime quand quand on n'a pas besoin de
parler quand il ya prés question à se
poser quand quand une quand on respire
l'un avec l'autre canton des fontaines
comme disait l'autre jour la femme
[Musique]
mais on devine england's a mis en garde
à israël après on coule tchéky karyo
[Musique]
oui
et
mais
[Musique]
t
[Applaudissements]
j
[Musique]
il
une tournée
un an
[Musique]
tu sais
mais que mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jours
monsieur
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
on va te faire un puce mois + moi c'est
quoi
et
mais
scénario de l'ours et quoi tu étais le
plus plu
[Musique]
rencontrer jour sakho
est-ce que tu as détesté ce qui t'a fait
chier quand à lui c'est là pas du tout
iberia qui t'a fait chaînon jean-jacques
d'ailleurs me dit m'avait dit avant que
je lise il m'avait dit tu sais c'est les
ours les stars il avait joué les ours
avant il a déjà vu ça va mal c'est vrai
mais en le lisant gt gt vraiment
fascinée et attirée par part
par la gageure du film et je skie me
plaisait aussi c'est que le personnage
il a quand même
chaque fois que l'homme rencontre les
jours si tu veux la dynamique entre
l'homme de l'ours passe beaucoup à
travers comme le personnage que je joue
donc c'est quand même chose qui m'attire
est
et puis la perspective d'être à cheval
d'être dans la montagne c'était ça me
plaisait beaucoup pas cadeau qu'est ce
que tu préfères chez du sein vivacité il
est très pétillant j'adorais
j'adorais la manière dont il jubilait il
jubilait son plateau c'est à dire
beaucoup de mes indications je les ai
prises dans son dans le sourire dans le
plaisir qu'il avait à faire le film que
moi j'avais cherché mes indications là
bas ou est-ce que tu as détesté chez
veolia maintenant ce que j'ai détesté
ouais che hanno à ça c'est dur c'est dur
c'est quelqu'un qu'on peut détester à
l'infini ou qu'on peut les aimer à
l'infini alors bien avouer que tu
supportes pas chez lui quelquefois ccc
sa courtoisie qui m'agace un peu parce
que tu penses qu'elle est fabriqué je
pense pas qu'elles soient fabriqués
c'est sûrement évidemment une façon
d'être mais je pense que c'est
profondément ancrée en lui c'est une
façon de se présenter
donc on peut l'aimer pour ça aussi mais
quelquefois on a l'impression que
l'église dessus comme comme la peau d'un
poisson ce que tu préfères chez les
hawks est ce que cette affaire chez les
zoulous leur curiosité
ils sont très curieux et très joueur
paraît qu est ce que tu déteste le plus
chez les hawks bien truquée faits
reprochés les ours à l'eau je comprends
que tu veux pas en parler mais les ours
vraiment crois moi j'ai je vois pas ce
que je pourrais d'été sécher le jeu
parce qu'en fait bon j'ai eu des
contacts avec eux il faudrait que je dis
peut-être beaucoup plus longtemps elles
et pour savoir ce que je déteste chez
eux que les critiques pourrait dire de
mieux sur ce site c'est quoi j'ai passé
à y voir
je sais pas si ce qui pourrait le dire
c'est j'ai rencontré quelqu'un là dans
les couloirs de la radio tout à l'heure
qui disait si les gens sont pas émus par
ce film il ya plus rien à faire pour que
elle est rentrée elle n'était pas
spécialement gagné avant d'arriver et
tout d'un coup elle s'est assise dans la
salle elle se rappelle plus comment il
s'appelait n'avait plus qu'à aller avait
été embarqué dans un autre monde
qu'est-ce qui pourrait dire de plus mes
choix ce qui pourrait dire plus les gens
[Musique]
je
c'est un bon garçon je suis un très beau
lancement et ça c'est un reproche que je
pourrais me faire
alors guy konopnicki brice couturier
vous allez être soumis pour la sortie de
votre bouquin réflexion sur la question
veille à l'interview vous vous seriez
valence élise le nom propre et vous
allez réagir en fonction de ce que vous
en pensez
[Musique]
il
m
toi brice si je te dis que l'apnée qui
tu me dis quoi j'ai d'excellents amis
juifs et toi tu es même si je te dis
couturier away couturier c'est un groupe
formidable qui en a eu marre d'être
maigre et que s'est mis à écrire sur 100
m alors on continue jean paul sartre
sartre un homme qui sait beaucoup trompé
il a écrit réflexions sur la question
juive ya pas de questions juives y a qu
une question goy edouard drumont edouard
drumont la france vive la france vive et
s'il y avait une france goy dire suite
qu'on envisage c'est la france doit y
avec dénonciation comme y at il un
complot gaulle dans les médias par
exemple charles maurras charlesbourg à
savatan c'était déjà un vieux con karl
marx karl marx encore un qui a voulu
l'écrire sur la question juive encore un
qui s'est trompé heureusement qu'on
était à adolf hitler dur avant lui il a
voulu trouver une solution finale était
sûr j'ai eu les mêmes paris jésus-christ
s'écrivent c'est le tentative de
tentative de faire passer les principes
du judaïsme déchets les peuples goy avec
des résultats mitigés fait marcher quand
même
en fait c'est une très bonne affaire et
sa mère la vierge marie swedish mais
c'est ça ouais c'est le maire j'ai eu
une bonne mère juive mais on n'en dit
pas plus parce que dès qu'on parle de
jésus ou de la vierge marie et l'éveil
qui manifestent donc christophe colomb
christophe colomb a essayé type qui
croyaient en fait tu sais qu'il est
parti juste l'année doublé juifs ont été
expulsés d'espagne est probable qu'en
fait il est parti là-bas parce qu'ils
pensaient faire ce qu'on appelle faire
son allié intérieur la terre promise
prêt et il sait pas gouré en fait les
skill à des pleurs broadway le bronx et
bronze
coluche pour à cogiter avec norman pas
juive pas belge
l'obejctif pas tout à fait quand même
cher veut lui coller ces tests est
formidable parce qu'ils disaient des
trucs sur un deuxième degré total et
quand on ouvre la télé on entend des
mecs qui rebute a même faut sérieusement
la vie d'andré malraux andré malraux
c'est typiquement le pour la question le
gorille est il apte au voyage expérience
de malraux c'est le type qui découvrent
des tombes dans une atmosphère à la
flash gordon
il ya des serpents là soyons et
et en fait il est incapable de voyages y
revient tout le temps antoine pinay
avoir antoine pinay c'est le grand héros
français sahiron formidable parce que
quand on regarde par exemple en israël
ils ont jamais eu un homme politique
dont toute la carrière était fondé sur
l'argent avec la monnaie
jamais un type capable de sauver le
shekel comme comme pinet est sauvée de
francs deux fois sinon il a eu la
francisque agissent devrait voir et
c'est une destinée tragique c'est
c'est un homme qui aurait voulu souffrir
il a tout fait pour il était emboliser
comme lcd n'est jamais arrivé lors son
dernier truc a été il a décidé d'être de
gauche pour être enfin dans une minorité
ouais enfin bon c'est tellement ils ont
gagné les élections
bref us dreyfus d'ainsi pas tellement
dreyfus nous intéresse c'est mafara ce
que c'est
d'abord parce que j'ai mis six
techniques dreyfus tubert c'est un
capitaine doit exister sur une île et
dreyfus sur la pub il a eu dix ans sur
son île et en plus ils étaient 1200 mah
fort il est coupable il a fait le 10
mois montre bien là aussi le céline
c'est à toi kabila me danse est lui
passé pour toi tu habites chez céline
oui c'est moi c'est du jeu c'est céline
j'ai avait d'un côté alors si je dis que
céline
ces classements dont les clients
préférés c'est alors par des problèmes
est et ouest
céline ce cas de casse terrifiant et de
commun avec pagnol c'est que le goy
quand il parle soit des femmes soient
des juifs il parle à son charme
c'est la fameuse règle eu avec tonton et
puis si la même chose à y perdre in qui
parle à webber de ses malheurs et qui
lui vit tout le nazisme a été un panneau
mensongers pour tromper l'auto louis
ferdinand céline ce qu à une force et
phare de ce que vous avez la forêt sent
tout de suite là faurisson c'est donc ce
type dont chacun sait qu'il dit que les
chambres à gaz n'ont jamais existé parce
que c'est ça les embête
donc nous on a inventé la vie de brian
may cry d'err faurisson vont expliquer
qu'on cesse jamais été kelly a jamais eu
persécution à barbie lui série b barbie
barbie c'est quand même c'est quand même
une belle destinée retrouve est revenu à
montluc voir se repasser le film des
tortures tous les joueurs et xynthia
jeté là il est traduit un là-bas parce
qu'il soutient à cet endroit là je me
rappelle celui là les électrodes celui
là vivement le pen à l'open c'est
et plus sérieux parce que le pénible
il était censé rome réhabiliter l'image
de la france du moins c'est ce qu'il
raconte est en fait nous fait beaucoup
de tort c'est quand tu parles avec un
américain et un anglais ou en allemand -
danois de 10 ha bon aure la france et de
ville fascistes mais si on est réaliste
et s'est repliée sur elle-même jal
entier c'est un type très dangereux
ouais pas parce que si on dit le pen a
joué ou un truc comme ça ça fera pas le
même effet sur lui pardonne moi c'est
moi c'est noir près par les médias
allemands le coup le breuil d'arafat
c'est que quand les nations boys ont
voulu redéfinir leur nord territoire
essayez de savoir une comment tellement
de gaulle où s'arrêtait le monde juif
ils l'ont fait sans les juifs en 47 ils
ont rendu une copie absolument
épouvantable par apax dépatouille avec
ça maintenant
mais hlb hr et ben c'est un débiteur
formidable parce que la plupart du temps
c'est le bien ouais vous êtes chez les
femmes mais le reste du temps je sais
grâce à je suis jamais allé je suis chez
lui comme un sujet du commun avec brice
serait dit bhl a écrit un merveilleux
roman que les derniers jours 200
baudelaire moi j'avais beaucoup ça
autre encore meilleure parce que les
prix pensez à vous à bella bella mots
mais là nous c'est notre patron à tous
les gens remarquent patron de globe qui
est commissaire paru mal gré
c'est quand vous avez fait preuve est
toujours là on attend prochainement
ça s'arrose avec wiz kebabs mais on est
jean jacques
plus bassiste descendeur le plus grand
bonheur des bassistes et plus franglais
comme moi tu me rends
[Musique]
et
bon
[Musique]
qu'on lui donne
cela
[Musique]
mais free est bon
doucet
[Musique]
dans
m
[Musique]
pour tout ce que j'ai
image unique rempart
qui sait
il sera par ici
il
ça
oh
[Musique]
j'ai nommé
son
enfants
bah
vim
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus encore qu'en faire
[Musique]
je préfère
c'est
que font
[Musique]
j'ai deux mois
[Applaudissements]
oui
en fait
m
ce qui fait
je vais
le bras vrai sûrement pas
m
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé ça tellement j'étais du
morceau sexy
[Musique]
en même temps comme pas sur moi pour
toutes les entités tout bas
[Rires]
[Musique]
indique aussi un petit plat be en fille
qui était habillé en fille maintenant
les cheveux courts mer jaune là là je me
souviens pas
bonjour tu le savais bah oui mais jma ya
gilles vesco on a déjà des le savez le
saluer sa mémoire de sa vie enfin la
fusée columbia
j'ai pas loin mes lunettes y'en a
combien vaut un paquet et moi j'arrive
facile
[Musique]
salomon tu fais quoi me catherine
intégral c'est le type la sécurité nous
voilà voilà
j'ai même temps on peut dire de moi tu
peux le dire la latte enchaîne les vingt
ans
[Musique]
honteux
oui je sais
à cannes mais je n'ai pas dit jouer mon
dieu ou quoi mais pourquoi et votre
flamme en haïti
[Musique]
je devrai tortue bleue
c'est quoi le jeu se grippent la mouche
tout le monde assiste extrait du jus
dans des tentes
[Musique]
j'ai dit voilà voilà
ça s'appelle comment ça religieuses du
monde il est beau mais ça a été des
mangeurs d'entrée sous les pieds j'étais
pas vraiment fan j'ai découvert 6 7 4 le
nombre voilà ça lui en fait six familles
que c'est l'allemagne
on a trouvé six sur huit et la motown à
trouver les nouveaux jackson seul
problème ils sont quatre mais qu'est ce
que c'est bien le boy's imac
[Musique]
et
sud est
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
il y en a
[Musique]
ouais
et
[Musique]
m
je viens
[Applaudissements]
com
[Musique]
m
la banlieue
[Musique]
oh
gordon c'est ta première interview à
télé talent prague roman noir que toi
parce que tu t'éclates dans un film qui
s'appelle drôle d'endroit pour le rende
dupeyron avec depardieu et deneuve tu
joues la serveuse de snacks
été assez bien dans ce film tout public
c'est la première fois qu'on a compris
zl1 pourquoi tu dis ça
tall et des interviews la première fois
qu'on a compris au sens artistique se
passe et faire comprendre
ils ont la vie courante puis j'ai
rencontré des gens qui nous a fait
on nage intelligent pied quoi supporter
avant séparé qu'il y ait des moments
durs là sur le bord de l'autoroute
des moments durs non
enfin moi je vous ai pas sentis pas
tellement j'ai pas subi trop de tension
j'étais complètement aux années ça s'est
passé comment ta vie
j'étais à pau là j'étais à pau et puis
en fin de droits enfin je me suis
inscrite en fac de droit
ouais je m'autorise et une bonne avocate
a non pas du tout je connais je suis
jeune et c'est de partir pour moi je
suis partie en sept manches paris a
aussi inscrit dans l'accord il paraît
qu'un jour tu as vu un livreur picture
show et puis à une panne de courant des
montées sur cette affaire tout le monde
c'est vrai c'était à pau
grandmont c'était une super soirée donne
sept heures à l'aube et
il ya une panne de projecteurs et puis
on tenait absolument à ce que l'ambiance
est donc un copain qui montait la can en
même temps je pense qu'on l'a suivi
je suis restée toute seule sur la scène
diffusée sur 7/7 plans radicaux
ben j'en restais en des femmes enceintes
jeunes ont miné tout ce qu'ils faisaient
ouais je vais là
d'accord donc je suis et les conneries
un peu pitre alors quand même c'est vrai
qu'on tapait la peau est compétitive
dans le car si j'étais quoi notre
quartier très populaire jean mach ellen
powell
et si tu es pressé
bon sang mais quand j'étais toute petite
tu pensé qu'un jour tu t'en sortir et où
terry jones sentiment que ça allait
arriver comme ça inconsciemment j'avais
jamais fond
en fait je me suis laissée je me suis
assez vite
j'ai écouté la vie ça à ce jour
la vie en fait ça marche c'est un truc
de dingue tu t'laisses aller et quand
est arrivée à paris tu as fais comment
pour vivre tout ça au début je n'ai pas
droite à gauche par an et demi et bien
c'est d'ailleurs chez les copains et
copines dans des squats dans le square
et puis
ensuite les touristes et puis voilà je
suis toujours toujours relativement
alors c'est quoi ton rôle rêve parce que
je veux faire
faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'en choisissant ce métier qui a
toutes les chances de paris moins bien
donc oui je sais mais ça je voulais
décrire les riches ne pas aller tous les
jours
vraiment c'est quand même la chance de
faire ce métier
moi je vous dis pas m'aider
c'est un jus l'appareil un gir cépages
français en chasse
les amours les amours
m
grand petit événement important
ah bon
c'est quoi comme signe le premier amant
c'était à quel âge
comprenez combien
j'avais 3 à 5 et bernard la région
s'étaient déjà sentir la tendance du
flirt avec lui dans les caisses du
secours à prendre la compétence un
nouveau défi des le pays renferme ses
bas
donc à chaque fois que tu avais tester
attaques souvent des histoires mais à
chaque fois tu es assez fidèle quoi
profonde d'agir quand même temps
l'histoire
ces dépenses and a day un jour à deux
ans bonjour à deux ans je n'ai plus
besoin des jalouses
[Musique]
changer la canopée ça te faire j'ai pas
envie de savoir
et si un jour tu rencontres le grand
amour c'est prête à abandonner sa
carrière réfléchit bien ce que tu
galères
enfin je peux bien mon pote je peux pas
avoir une rampe à l'intérieur je peux
pas
l'enfant
[Musique]
jones ex au palace filmé par sylvain
bergère avant libre oui le performeur
londonien le 27 octobre jean-claude la
grèce et son french kiss nous ont offert
le performeur new york et cris prache
ce soir je serai à poubelles recurt ben
ali c'est lui qu'on l'entende
pourquoi
on
et comment
[Musique]
pour
m
ep
et
[Rires]
[Musique]
sachez qu'avant soir enfin pas tout à
fait remis en question quel est le nom
du jeune
[Musique]
deuxième question combien tu as vendu de
trop de blabla
2 3 millions n'ont même pas un an chez
pas cent mille peut-être 100 milles et
toi comment tu as vendu de la mort d'el
aux serveurs
donc tu as gagné déjà tu marques tu
connais le jeu pas bien juste voir c'est
facile je pose des questions par exemple
tu connais malatini et les mahotella
queens ou bien sûr ils ont fait un
morceau qui s'appelle case est oui alors
en france s était chantée par qui a 10
ans et ça s'appelait comment ce que
chantait paralysie mercier descloux et
ça s'appelait mais où sont passées les
gazelles
bravo bat chouette on marque un point
déjà alors à toi maintenant mais quel
était le nom c'est tout l'effet galles
quel était le nom de la femme de john
lennon de la première dix mois la
première et la deuxième
cynthia way locaux et north pole ici
c'est beau et sa mère dame a man 2
john a appelé elle s'appelait s'appelait
annoncé commencer courant anna et la mer
il a fait une chanson qui s'appelle
comme ça julien marouene solide
la masse ça fait un partout pour le
moment elle est forte alors les restes à
reconnaissent l'autorité d'une ampleur
d'ethiopie comment s'appelait le dernier
empereur d'ethiopie haïlé sélassié oh là
là réviser ou pas commencer le minibus
et les voilà tous à matha morceaux des
beatles qui a été repris par les stones
[Musique]
ou en payant mais bravo c'est ça la ccl
alors quelle est la chanson qui a été
chanté par
tracy chapman bruce springsteen sting à
la
à la fin du concert d' amnistie à bercy
ap un non mais moi j'ai fais pas un
morceau de marley très connu même en ce
moment elle est très connue ailleurs je
veux dire au pif ah bon
personne tsonga phone le souffle c'est
par sa tante qui veut dire ça commence
par kenneth j'ai un jésus
voix avant les ingénieurs
[Musique]
et
j'ai été
get up stand up where quel est le nom du
songwriter de la motown qui a fait un
disque qui sape les hippies ne purent
goutte d'eau une back to you route d'un
monde d'osier rome la prochaine fois je
le ferai encore plus dur tu reviendras
en deuxième semaine je les ferai encore
plus dur
quel est le titre du morceau d'anisette
qui lui même pays que les parents vers
je connais la chanson mais je sais
absolument pas comment ça s'appelle la
chanson tu sais pas je sais qu'elle est
basse a comme moi en plus des pasteurs à
douala oui en plus je connais très bien
sa vie alors je sais pas la donne
il marque un poil
quel est l'autre chanson qu'a reprise
piaf parce que finalement la foule à la
touche découverte lors de la mode pointe
de latence et deux auteurs américains
trek très tonique en beauce et toi la
maman mais c'est quoi ce que parce que
ça c'est l'île aux immenses pas d'amendé
il s'est plaint
leiber et stoller bravo voilà tu gagnes
d'un poil il a gagné d'un point est
connu voilà c'est fini bande de nazes va
trouver lunettes noires s'applique le
chat pour les yeux rouges
y'a rien de tel
[Musique]
moi oui
oui
m
[Musique]
et
et pas
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus